why would someone who loves movies and
writing quit the film business you know
it's interesting we get into an industry
that seems so romantic to other people
and they'll say that people have said
that to me oh my god how could you have
been working in movies and leave almost
like we're beholden to that and now
we're not allowed to go have you know a
new career
and even though there are many aspects
of movies that i loved and continue to
love
there were a lot of
areas that were challenging
like distribution for your movie
financing your movie and you'd spend
years putting together a film writing it
finding the team finding the money you
put a labor of love into it and then
nobody would buy it and nobody would see
it and that to me just was
a little bit too heartbreaking for
longer than 20 years
and so you made a feature film was it at
19. i made 11 films and i started at 21
and the first couple ones calista
flockhart who ended up becoming ally
mcbeal she was in a film that we were
sort of an associate producer on which
is kind of how you get started when
you're young in in i don't know if it's
the same now but back in the day that's
that's what it was and what that
basically meant was is we found
something for free basically
because that's how you operated then
because everybody was on such a
shoestring and then after that you know
now you say oh i've been an associate
producer right so then you get an
opportunity to be an associate producer
on another film and then next thing you
know it's just you start to learn more
and then you're able to start taking on
producer producer credits
did anyone sit you down in the beginning
and say
you know this is a this is a get ready
to wait type of a business and people
will tell you all sorts of stuff and
then you'll never hear from them again
or did you have to learn that there were
no mentors
we had women in film which i didn't find
i found was a little uh like
non-inclusive
um and so you'd volunt i did a couple
volunteering
gigs there and then i was like i don't
know i don't know it just it it
as a woman in a man's business and
especially as a young woman
you didn't really want to let people
know that you didn't know
so there was a lot of kind of fumbling
around in the dark
to
you learned from your mistakes basically
so when you make one mistake you're like
well let's not make that mistake again
when you worked in hollywood producer
writer production coordinator did you
have any other jobs
no i didn't i in the very beginning i
was a temp
so when i was in new york city i had
some pretty crazy temp jobs and
um we were making this movie we were
kind of getting ready to make this movie
at the time and i was really stoked
because i think it wasn't like lehman
brothers or like one of the like
i don't remember what the bank was that
the guy went and sold everything and
crashed the whole bank i was there like
working for the person i think i i try
to i can't remember exactly but i look
back and i'm like oh my god i think i
reported to his office but they had
these like massive
xerox machines
so we needed what was called um pages
and we also needed the schedule printed
on like blue paper and green paper and
pink paper and we had no money this is
awful but this is what you would do to
make movies is i would sneak into the
copy room and when no one was looking my
damn job i'd whip out like 400 copies of
you know a colored schedule for the
for the production
okay
so and no one found out no i was pretty
wily okay and i did my job i did my job
i got my job done but it was a little
bit too in the in the movie business
that i felt there was this like
justification
that as i grew into more integrity in my
life and especially the business i'm in
now my company a story inside i had to
look back and there were a lot of things
that you were kind of expected to do or
thought you had to do
to for the art
and i look back now and i think that was
one of them it's like i was stealing
if you think about it that wasn't my
paper they were not paying me for that
job and we would do other things like
you know
fill water bottles that we had gotten we
bought maybe one
poland spring bottle
and then we'd fill it with a hose for
the rest of the production but we
wouldn't tell anybody you know just
you know and then you'd be like well it
saves money and it's for the art and i i
just over time you start to think
i don't want to
try to unpay people and rip people off
anymore it just doesn't feel like that's
what that art should be
sure sure and and was that later on
after you left the film industry that
you sort of had that
sort of making amends type
exactly i mean
i think because it was every you know
like everybody did it there was just not
i mean we were pretty you know we were
pretty sneaky in new york we made some
pretty we did some pretty sneaky things
i think i remember there was a story we
didn't do anything dangerous like we
didn't put anybody's lives at risk and i
remember there was that film where they
were like they didn't have a permit they
were shooting on the railroad tracks and
a couple people died wasn't that here in
california recently and i was just
thinking
oh no we didn't cross that line yeah
we worked in some pretty scary places we
didn't cross that line interesting
and then you left and then i left
voluntarily or the economy it was kind
of like i had a baby in 2005. we left
los angeles to uh you know maybe have a
little bit more of like a suburban life
which almost killed me um it was a
little too suburban for me it was like i
went from echo park in la which is
really rough and like artists over to
suburban san jose
and just there wasn't really any access
to any film anymore um i tried to keep
writing screenplays
um i did write one in 2010
and that was the last one
and so contrary to what people say that
you can be anywhere and be writing a
script did you feel that to be true no
i think you have to be in los angeles to
take the meetings
meet the people
collaborate with others on their
projects
right place right time know the
attorneys know the agents
i i don't think you can do it anywhere
else
have people fought you on that yeah i
mean i haven't really talked to anybody
about it in a while um
but i think there's those few
movies that are made in other places
that originate from other places you
know they're made in florida and they
break through but the breakthrough is
typically through
agents or people that are in la that
like might see the film and suggest it
for a festival or they're involved in
sundance um i think there's some
component that has to be in los angeles
but you did write a script while you
were in the bay area yeah i did i did
and those people had contacted me from
my contacts in l.a
so they weren't people i met in the bay
area when you told people in the bay
area that you were in the film industry
previously or that you were writing a
script what was their reaction
i don't really think i told anybody oh
you didn't oh okay a closet screenwriter
okay i like it i don't think they they
like they had nothing to do with the
film business they were like they would
have been like okay okay i see you right
like your mom's group you know
they're talking about kids i see okay so
it never came up
yeah meanwhile i was writing this like
her you know horrific torture script so
i don't think it would have been like a
great conversation sure you wouldn't be
invited to the birthday exactly they'd
be like look out watch out for her
you took a part-time job at trader joe's
one of my favorite stores um do you want
to talk about how that transition came
about sure
i think whenever like you leave
something that's your identity you know
i since i was little i always you know
was talking into a hairbrush and so
i've actually discovered i always
thought that was an actress
or eventually i thought it was a
filmmaker and lately i've realized it's
i want to be a talk show host right so
you know you wake up to that in your 50s
and you're like oh my god and it's all
these transitions we have to go to and i
like to call it like the breaking down
of the ego self right to really get
under what it is you really want to do
and i had come back to los angeles
gotten divorced and had two small kids
and
didn't want to go back in the movie
business i didn't want to go back and be
like a production assistant i had done
that been there done that and i felt i
would probably have to start in the
beginning again
and to me just getting a job at trader
joe's just seemed like
it's where it's like somewhere safe
for eight hours to just be a worker
among workers which i really felt i
needed to do
i honestly did not 100 need the money my
ex-husband was working
um
but that eleven dollars an hour i had
not made a paycheck in a little while
and that eleven dollars an hour was like
really special to me oh sorry i remember
when the manager they had reviews
i've never been reviewed in my life i've
always been my own boss
and he took me outside and he said
kim the one big note we have for you is
it's time for you to
step up to your true potential
and i just started sobbing
on a bench in westwood and i think he
was like
oh my god because it hit it was so true
that this guy had seen this in me you
know
and he was like okay well we're going to
give you your 30 cent raise i was like
thank you thank you so much and it it
just really made me see how i'd always
been kind of hiding in the shadows
so from having retail jobs myself you
know you you interact with so many
people some are wonderful some maybe not
so much but there's always interesting
characters were you watching some of the
patrons come in even though you were
busy working i'm sure but
yeah one eye was like you know that
would make a great character right there
i didn't really think of it as like
because i was having an experience on
such a personal level like i'm sure in
my writing because i still write i write
all the time but i you know i think that
those you know they come you remember
them but at the moment i wasn't like oh
that's a good character like versus when
i was in the film business i was always
like that but now i was just having the
experience with people as
it was almost freeing it was like it
wasn't for anything it was just to have
the experience and
the people that i worked with there was
a guy who
was a you know he had been a convict
and we commiserated over tattoos and i
went to his tattoo guy
and there were just there was like a
two guys that were married and like i
got to know them and so just to getting
to know there was a another worker who
had lost a baby at like
six months
and we would hug every morning
nobody needed to say anything we were
just like two people trying to process
and so there was a lot of that beautiful
energy in that store
and
then there were the people that would
come in they were the moms
who
were
going to the same kids went to the same
school as my kid down the street and
they would come in and they would like
kind of corner me and they'd be like
desperate to get divorced but they
didn't know if they could financially
support themselves so they wanted to
know how i did it i'm like i'm not
financially supporting myself yet on
trader joe's but
you know here you know you got to make
the leap and you got to know you know
you got to figure it out and
they were just so fascinated by my
courage to work there
and
um there were some very self-entitled
people
um my daughters love this story there
was a woman who came in now you could do
what's called carryout service
where you don't really have to have a
reason you don't have to be handicapped
or anything you can just demand carryout
service right
and this woman demanded the carryout
service and as we're as i'm pushing her
card she turns around and looks me and
she goes
run
and i was like every east coast punky
part of me was just like i am going to
tell this woman where to put it
and so instead i just slowed down
and i just got the cart there and i
walked back in and
two of my friends at work there were
just sort of waiting for me and they
look and they go so how did that go and
i was like oh my god you guys didn't
warn me they're like oh my god we can't
stand that woman
and it was like she does that to
everybody she's like we are there for
her sure you know
um and then there was a couple of a man
who
got uh racially um
verbally abusive with an iranian woman
and it was like you know she wasn't
moving fast enough this is like
the trader joe's i worked at we would
have these peak hours where every
register all eight would be
full
and you'd just be so stressed and so
then for something explosive to happen
at your station was like
it was just puts you into like a state
of shock and he said something about
like you know learn how to use your card
you and he called her a slur name
and she just turns around and she's like
i'm an md
and they just started going at it and
the manager had to come over and it was
we had some intense stuff
so at that time had you been writing uh
your memoir or
that i had not even
come to terms with
i don't think i had even
had the dream about the sexual abuse yet
so the memoir is about waking up and
realizing that i had been sexually
abused for most of my childhood so
i had not woken to that yet um i think
that was
one year after
and so with dreams you'd always been
empathic so you've always been very
sensitive to picking up
i didn't know i was until in the last
six years
yeah i've really stepped into that i
probably have been my whole life it's
just you can suppress that stuff and
just not even know what that is until
you start
kind of being in circles of people that
are empathic that are intuitive that
start to tell you you're psychic you
start to see energy move in the
direction in which your thoughts are
empowering it and so
um i do believe abuse survivors have an
extra dose of that because of the
disassociation
right and having to be hyper aware of
their surroundings yeah for survival
right
so at what point did you think about
writing
what happened
did people
talk you out of it
i didn't tell anybody i just started
doing it like i just knew that i had to
write this book and i knew that writing
the book was the way through
which is what i tell a lot of my book
clients it's like just write the story
just work your way through it just get
that first draft down because what
you're going to then share
to the reader who needs you
that'll come out in that second draft
once you get it all down so i just wrote
and wrote and wrote and wrote
and
then later just kind of readjusted it to
like
some of the anger or some of the some
some stuff that was a little bit too
journaly i took out just to really so i
could i wanted to put it into categories
for people like
explaining how sexual abuse affects
every area of your life sexuality
spirituality capacity to make money
masculine and feminine energy
everything it somehow skews your
perception in all those areas and so i
just kind of broke it down by the way i
saw my life having been dictated about
with the abuse without even really
knowing that's what was
happening did you confront the person he
was dead ah okay yeah okay yeah uh
forgive me if this is too personal and
we can stop if it is did you talk to
other people that may have been around
at that time i did i part of the process
was i called my mom because it was my
dad
and um received a big dose of i don't i
didn't know
there
and then called my cousin so i've been
close with growing up and actually
called not both i actually only called
one of the three cousins who i who i'm
more close to and he was just
so sympathetic and devastated and no
nobody denied it you know told my one
aunt his mom
and tried to tell my sister she didn't
want to hear it
it's just so interesting your family
like who will you know
my daughter my teenage daughter who's
now 15 and a half
i'm not going to beat myself up about it
but i did tell her fairly young i think
she was
12 or 13 as old as my current 12 year
old is now who knows nothing
and
i think cause she was the first born it
was sort of like you look at them as
more ready to handle it she came to a
book signing
and she went through a lot of fear for a
little while about
the legacy of our family she was afraid
of like how it was going to be carried
down even though there's no we've
already broken the legacy there's no
abuse in our
structure
so um
it's one of those things i learned like
we need to empower our children
but they're still it's still like
it's still a very scary subject
for
for young people
can you talk about making decisions from
high self-esteem versus low self-esteem
sure
i think now the decisions that i make
are
you know really looking at like
what i want as in the bigger picture
versus
the data like everything used to be so
important day to day like the outcome of
what you know the voices in my head and
what they would say you know like oh you
didn't do that right or you didn't make
enough money or that person's not happy
or
i can't change
anybody's opinion i can't make anybody
happy and i can't necessarily make
anybody sad unless i've done something
erroneous which i could apologize for
but the higher the higher self-esteem is
definitely from that place of more
thinking
i'm good
like i've got this like i'm on the
higher ground like i know where i'm
going like the world
everything that i want is already
available to me
versus before and this was a lot in the
movie business just a lot of just uh
financial chaos you know
fearing
being you know like
criticized or
just not being enough
you know
i don't feel that way now
and do you think a large part of it has
to do with the dream and sort of
coming clean with your past even though
it was no fault of your own but just
realizing
what happened and what you had
suppressed oh yeah i
i think when you've been abused there's
a natural feeling that you're damaged
goods and that like you're dirty right
and you and especially if you haven't
faced it you just are like confused
while you're why you're
um why you feel different
you know inside and a lot of abuse
survivors um turn to drugs and alcohol
to just because it's just some there's
something wrong
but they don't know what it is right so
you're in the unknown
where for some people i mean even now
the unknown can be like oh my god but
like
you're in the unknown and it's like um
it's almost like you're dying it's that
painful right because you're
you're untethered to something right
like you might not be tethered to the
abuser anymore but you're
you're in there if you don't have faith
then you're not tethered there so drugs
and alcohol are a great great way for
you to feel powerful
because you're making a decision to
do something i'm gonna get
messed up
and i'm gonna be messed up and that's a
clear cut decision
and outcome
where everything else really
involves other people
and you can also hang out with other
people like-minded that are want to do
it too right oh yeah it's a very social
thing oh yeah yeah in my 30s i hung out
with just just just terrible people
that did all sorts of drugs
and i don't know if they had any abuse
in their history i'm
probably i mean they were
it was again it was like
oh we're filmmakers
that's what filmmakers do they do a lot
of
um
and then it just is not just doesn't
work anymore i'm comedian i mean i you
know when when i moved back when i moved
to la and in my 30s like
when i first got this whole thing going
in la um
there were a lot of just
people that were doing a lot of drugs
do you think that's why
the trader joe's experience was also
because you felt you could just be
yourself
whereas with the mom's group
you had to be something
right you couldn't uh you didn't want to
scare a mom
you know with who i really was right
they could be the same way but right
they didn't want to
have that out go there it's true trader
joe's we were just all a bunch of
misfits it was so so true and i
feel most comfortable
i i'm i'm someone that can kind of get
along with everybody
but i'm always going to have a little
bit of like a
i like people with a little bit more of
like a edge you know that like the thing
kind of thing like we can laugh about
the way we think and it's a little nutty
and we don't have to be too apologetic
because life is just life
and yeah i don't do well with a lot of
like um
[Music]
surficial
relationships
and were you like that before the memoir
or or that's yes but in a very angry way
so there was a lot of anger you know
like why am i feeling like this all the
time there's a lot of yelling i have a
whole section in the book where i talk
about the rage
and how you're just constantly just
yelling at people and you don't know why
and you don't know
what's behind all that rage right and
and movies were a great place for that
because again it was justified i'm
painting such a horrible picture of the
movie business i loved making movies by
the way and there were a lot of
beautiful people and i had a lot of
great experiences but for me
it was a it was you it was okay for you
to scream at somebody
where now i'm like that's completely
unacceptable if i'm even snippy with
someone on my team now i apologize i
send them like a coffee card
but maybe that you know maybe it is
maybe it is
i think it's
i think it has to do with recovery from
abuse i think you do start to see and
you stu you do start to feel what it
feels like hurt people hurt people so if
you're not hurt anymore you're not
really wanting to hurt anybody anymore
and then i think you start to evolve on
the other side of like well if i'm not a
hurt person
then who am i actually going to be a
girlfriend of mine wrote a tv show
and this was seven years ago when i was
just kind of
i had been substitute teaching and i had
written my book i was starting to kind
of get get my feet going and
you know i don't think i'd even written
my book yet but i'd come to terms with
the abuse and she asked me to produce a
pilot
and i was like i'm not gonna produce a
pilot like i'm not going back into the
business and she's no we're gonna have a
great time and i'll pay you it'll be
really fun and
and i was like okay and i was newly
newly i had stopped drinking so i was
clean as a whistle and i was like all
right it's worth it and then someone
said to me when the job was done and we
had we had a great time and when the job
was done someone said to me you know why
don't you poll the people that worked
for you
and ask them
what they thought of you
and i was like
so
moved that not a single person called me
a yeller no one said i was aggressive
they said when i came in the room they
knew help was here
that i made them laugh that i was always
the last one to leave and i was like
what
and i knew that something big had
changed in my life and then i thought oh
i want to make a movie like this
it's the one thing i kind of wish that i
could make a movie
as the new me because i would show up on
that film set
very differently
very differently than i would have back
then it would i would have fun
what's the inciting incident in your
book it would be
waking up from the dream
absolutely
and sitting in my living room and really
thinking
oh
i know
and then
uh what do i do now
that's the inciting incident
there's
a whole journey that comes from that and
and most people like clients that i work
with in their books
it's usually that
that one t it's not always like the most
exciting moment necessarily it's that
that inside moment where you know
something's going to change forever
and it did
when you went to sleep the night before
had you watched a movie did something
happen do you think triggered it or no
it was just
this time
why did you procrastinate writing for so
long i know you had this realization but
didn't weren't there other things you
were putting off yeah i mean i think
that i had to go through a lot of
different experiences so that i could
know what to write about
so if i had just started writing right
away from the dream and i was i was
journaling everything so i had a lot of
good
material but i hadn't lived enough yet
to really see the difference right so
like i had to be a recovered sort of i
had to be a survivor for a little while
before i felt like i could really look
at
what i had slighted myself in in living
to write about what i could potentially
have and my second book which is written
and it's sitting on my laptop is all
about the next steps which is
you've put in a bunch of years as a
survivor you've seen the change and
you're ready to leave behind
that past of how you used to live and
you're ready to kind of now take this
new you into another level of your life
but i am procrastinating on it
i've decided i want to write another
book that's a lot more fun so
that can happen sometimes and get
distracted but i do believe everything
is in the right time so
um i know that my first book got
published so i know that another one
will
and i've actually
taken that book down the first memoir
um i took the rights back from the
publisher in december i don't feel like
the service was done that it deserves
people read it and they go this is like
the most amazing book i've ever read on
abuse this should be a worldwide book
and the publisher did not do a good job
so
and neither did i frankly because today
you have to be behind your book 100 you
can't rely on a publisher at all
and so i've taken the book rights back
i'm actually doing a second edition on
it i'm going to rename it and i'm going
to put it out under my own publishing
label
why rename it
kicking abuse in the ass was a very sort
of
yeah
kind of title right
and i want it to reach more people so
now i'm going to call it awoken
okay are you do you think the title
might scare certain people
uh
i i want to go more direct i think what
i've learned with my clients and helping
them come up with book titles and and
chapter headings
there's like there's a there's a fine
line between clever
and kind of not really telling people
what you're going to do for them in the
book like kicking abuse in the ass
it wasn't really what i was doing in the
book 100
it wasn't like i was going in there and
slaying it i was really being reflective
why do you think most writers
procrastinate
oh a whole i could give you the longest
list i hear i've heard everything
from i'm afraid of being famous
uh what will i do with all my time when
i'm famous how am i going to take care
um i don't want to upset my family
members
um
i don't know if i can finish something
i've started so they don't even start
uh i'm not i don't have a writing degree
like i don't have like a you know a
i'm not a graduate of the iowa state
writing you know writing conference so
why bother
um a lot of a lot of reasons a lot of
reasons i can't find time on my schedule
i don't understand what kind of support
i need i don't know what kind of
structure there should be
a million reasons
you had talked about you were looking to
maybe one day direct
uh write and direct as the new kim
what what you saw as the new kim do you
think people
don't know
what the new self would be as this
author if that like you talked about
this fear of being famous whatever but
also too they'd be taking on this new
persona
that maybe they'd be leaving victimhood
or whatever behind and now
can you talk about that oh yeah new
persona and how you
transformed into that i love that this
question is
such a beautiful question because it
comes up actually more
in the class i run called own your
authorship
where it's sort of that chasm between
like they have the desire to tell their
story but the yes feels like kind of far
you know
and people come in and they they take
the class and they're like a little bit
like
who are you and who do you you know a
little bit
like not chip on their shoulder but you
know let's see what you got you know
and i just work them till you know we
turn we do a prompt that's called i hate
you because
and
many people write about themselves
and then i make them go back and write
it about someone else and they go well i
don't want to hate somebody else i go
well you know you do
so why don't you tell us about it like
if you're going to get honest get honest
now we're not going to email it to them
just write it
and i think that that's um where they
start to unlock and they start to see
themselves and and start to be okay and
then they just really like you see a
shift immediately where there's they're
realizing wait a minute like i have a
story to tell and then we do you know
come find a picture of yourself in your
20s
some groups i'll do little kids like
i'll kind of intuitively gauge the group
i can tell very early on what i need to
do with people i'm very intuitive that
way and
from that writing about where they came
from you just see them start to just
like light up and then we talk about the
author persona and what is your author
persona like who would you be if you
were like a successful author what does
that look like would you have your own
jet
are you doing a book tour worldwide or
is this where you make all your income
and you see a lot of them like well i
don't know i mean is that part
we're not saying that's gonna happen or
not happen i just want you to write
about it you know
and so a lot of the resistance is the
um
it's almost like they feel like they're
saying something that's not true by
writing about it
even though it's a dream they have
so if you can get them to write about
the dream then the dream suddenly
doesn't seem so far-fetched
what do you think your biggest
resistance was to writing i think for me
a lot of it was time i was
single parenting
trying to build a business
and
i literally did not have any time i also
did not hire a coach
which i should have done when i finally
hired an editor everything moved really
fast because i was ready
but i think i just
i i you know i didn't take my own
medicine you know i didn't bring in
someone i was telling everybody that my
clients how important it is to be
coachable and i wasn't co being coached
so i'd say my resistance was i didn't
think that
i was worthy of
exactly what i tell my clients to
believe they're worthy of
how do you know you have the right coach
so i'm sure there's a gazillion coaches
editors out there
you know there's not a lot of book
coaches
um
that
necessarily do a white glove service i
don't hear about a lot of them i hear
about you know editors that might edit
your book over 90 days or um
and i'm doing more of like a deep dive
into like the whole
purview of the person like what do you
want to what does this book mean to you
like what do you want to be with this
book like i often help people come up
with
um
trademarkable systems or
business ideas or
mantras that they can actually then
claim as their own through the writing
of the book that they couldn't see
before i'll be like that's brilliant
nobody else is doing that and they'll be
like oh my god yeah
so i'm not sure that that's so much of
just an editor i think that is
definitely more of a coach because i'm
seeing the human potential
in that person
through what they're sharing with me
about who they are
um and then we happen to be writing a
book through it all
so is this someone who already has a
first draft finish
i don't take people typically on that
have a first draft because then we'd
have to break it all up and then i'm
just putting glue on something that's
probably broken so i like to work with
people from the very very start
so if i call you and say or email you
and say i would like to write about
my life
i don't even have an outline i'm just
telling you this is my desire and we're
going to go from there and structure it
together yep wow yeah that's that's my
favorite way to work because we really
just
start from this from scratch you know we
do the outline together and then we go
through
um eight months of work what are some of
the first questions you ask someone
it really depends on the people i mean i
don't have a formula
more than
outline day first draft second draft
third draft get the book published
i ask them a lot of questions before i
do the outline day with them and kind of
ask them about
you know tell me about three amazing
moments in your life you know
write to me about what you think about
yourself what were some of your greatest
accomplishments
um if they've told me a little bit about
uh something that happened in their life
or why they became a coach or
uh why they've been a binge eater or you
know what it was like in the navy i'll
say give me a couple scenes on that
because from that i can sort of get a
tone
of what it would be and then and a lot
of that is movie business work you know
kind of seeing what the scenes are and
then wrapping around the scenes a
narrative for the book
do you ever ask them the why
yeah we do that knowing your authorship
we work out the why
generally because people
that are not ready to write a book
the reason is because they're not
confident in their why
so that's why i have them take the class
people that come to be ready to be a
private client they're pretty rock
they've got a really good why it might
be a little bit smaller than they think
like i'll find a bigger why
but generally they come in with like
this is what i'm writing about and i
don't have to like work it
so these aren't wishy-washy people on
the fence they're they're like there's
no people that do my one year now
there's not a lot of convincing
i like to say like if someone comes to
me for a one year they're usually like
there's no cell
they're just in
but if i'm on the phone with someone for
a really long time then
generally they're not going to be a
client right away
do you talk to your clients about if
they write something traumatic what they
may feel physically oh yeah i've had
clients go down for the count for a
couple weeks
um just pure exhaustion of just sort of
reliving something or realizing
putting the patterns together
there's there's some dismay
um
there's some anger
you know we feel so much in our bodies
as creatives um
and sometimes they're connecting to
themselves in that way for the first
time and so
some things are kicked off if they have
like you know an autoimmune or something
like that um
i don't do like a medical
intake form but
i will
you know
um i kind of gauge it as we go like i
won't i don't want to scare them and
then put on them someone else's
experience like oh such and such wrote
about such and such and she was out for
the count like because they might not be
that person they might
muscle through
but i i do watch for it
did that happen to you
yeah
i um
right after the and it hadn't it wasn't
the writing yet so this is another
reason why i was delayed with the book
right after i
came to terms with the abuse i
um got an autoimmune disorder called
echolatia
and that's in like 1 in 200 000 people
and it's literally your voice
so it's just too it's just too
like
connected to
discount it but it
um
i
you asked the question about the high
you know the high self-worth and the low
self-worth
because i was so
i took care of myself like i took care
of myself on all like this
but inside of me i hadn't taken care of
myself in so long
that um
i just thought for like nine months
that i was having like jerred or like
some kind of like um
regurgitation i was having a lot of
regurgitation and i was getting skinnier
and skinnier and skinnier
and i remembered and then i couldn't eat
and then i went to see my regular doctor
and i walked into her office and she
the look on her face when she saw me and
she said have you looked in the mirror
at yourself and she dragged me over to
the mirror and i had like an abscess on
my chin
i was gaunt my
and she did all these labs and my blood
was um
attacking me
and they literally had to find a
specialist with appalachia within two
weeks and i was in a massive surgery in
three weeks
and so that it's an autoimmune disorder
and it was brought out i think it was
brought out i think it was probably
always suppressed
but i think when you just open up
sometimes you're gonna get the good and
sometimes you're gonna get the ugly and
that was definitely an ugly situation
so how long did that keep you
debilitated for that was um
i mean the recovery from it was pretty
quick once they do the surgery you're
you're better like you're better in five
days
um but just like getting my system back
going you know when your body has an
intake hasn't taken in any food really
for a long time everything has to
re-wake up
so it's kind of symbolic everything
started waking up plus you get into this
and a lot of women talk about this like
getting better is not getting skinny
so i had kind of fallen into this whole
i'm skinny
and then when my body started course
correcting back to what i should be
there was a lot of like oh my god like
i'm getting fatter and i didn't sign up
for this and
so there was a lot of looking at
you know
the pluses and minuses of my story like
when am i gonna be kim for real and then
that started to catch up and that's
about when i started write the book
what is a memoir a memoir is writing
about people's their lives and something
that they've experienced that they think
is extraordinary and if you think about
a classic one the glass castle
which was about a woman who just had
this
horrendous childhood and she's looking
back at it from being i think she was
very successful in business
so you almost can't believe
what she had been through to get to
where she was
um
it's just a retelling of it's a
retelling of your life and there's a new
sort of hybrid that's kind of crept into
the marketplace and that's the self-help
piece in the memoir
and that's all you know i don't
i wouldn't say my book is as much memoir
as it is self-help
because i'm not taking you to the past
i'm staying pretty much in
a small c like
a microcosm of adulthood i'm not talking
about my childhood at all
so your
your recount your your
adult kim thinking back having this
dream
sharing with the reader waking up
and the realization and then looking
back at sort of my adult life
why i behaved the way i behaved in my
adult life there's nothing we can do
about any of it anyway
going back to the childhood is not going
to necessarily give me any answers
except for like the original self right
which
you were when the day you were born and
then from there on it started to get
messed with anyway
so i didn't have a lot of memories of i
didn't want to write a tell-all about
abuse my situation was not violent and
it wasn't um
like particularly traumatic it was uh
almost like a continuing dream of
events that would come up in my memory
and i would think
oh that was odd that day we went down
that dirt why did we go down that dirt
road
but that was it like my mind was not
wanting me to know more than that and so
i made the decision that it would serve
my reader better if i focused on
what i feel the abuse had created for me
as problems and what i was starting to
become
had you read a lot of other memoirs i
know you mentioned the one before but no
you hadn't no
i think there's one called like they
call me dave or whatever there's some
really great yeah about people
remembering yeah i hadn't read any i
didn't want to have any
anybody's else's
you know uh experience
to affect my journey
so you didn't want to sort of mimic the
writing style yeah and i and i tend to
with writers who are writing memoirs i
might give them a memoir to read but i
often will give them books on writing to
read or
something that would not be like at all
in their category necessarily because i
don't want to put that on them like i
don't want them to start judging their
book against
this other book
what are some of those writing books
that you give them uh writing down the
bones by natalie goldberg is like
an amazing writer it's like probably the
best book about writing memoir
um anything ann and lamont writes is
just
just rita and lamont i mean
for her wit and her use of description
and the way she just sort of moves the
narrative along um
the war of art
uh is another phenomenal book i'm
forgetting his name right now
stephen pressfield steven pressfield
that is
um an excellent book there was a book
called
how to read as a new york times writer
or author and i'm not remembering her
name but it's literally like
she broke down every book that's
great to read by
if you want to learn about voice if you
want to learn about structure if you
want to learn about narrative if you
want to learn about flashback and i
remember one point in time i got the
book and i read them i read everything
and just reading
we we don't read enough and you become a
better writer when you read
yeah anne lamott's ted talk is great too
you know she she puts a lot of humor
yeah and she's very very easy to relate
to yeah and um
yeah
bay area personally yep she is
do you think it's important for anyone
who wants to write a book to begin
writing a memoir is that the first step
to writing a book or if someone wants to
write
a narrative that's
you mean like fiction or oh i think
anybody should write whatever they want
to write if you don't want to write a
memoir don't write a memoir because it's
definitely a very specific style of book
if you want to write a psychological
thriller you know learn how to write a
psychological thriller if you want to
learn how to
um you know write a like and lamont like
journal
sort of uh
witty repartee kind of book
write that um and there's you know
different
classes you can take in those specific
areas
for me i can coach anybody because i'm
not specifically a writing teacher
right so i'm not going to come in and
teach you how to be a better
psychological thriller writer i'm going
to help you have a better writer voice
for you
but i'm not necessarily
an expert in the psychological thriller
i might be an expert on great characters
or a great plot
so sometimes people ask me that they're
like well there seems to be like a
formula with certain books and i'm like
wow is there i don't know because i'm
that's not my genre
what are some common mistakes you see
new writers make that once they're at a
professional level you don't see as much
so what would so professional levels an
interesting
term because what would that be i mean i
i say to
my clients the minute you've made a
decision to write a book you are now a
professional author and you need to
think that way and if you have to take a
post-it and you have to put it on your
desk that says i am a professional
author or i am an author you need to do
that you need to put it everywhere in
your house until you actually believe
that you are of the same quality as
anybody else there's no like distinction
between you and the person who's super
famous or as a new york times bestseller
you have to own that within you first
and i think once they step to that then
it's really just it's time to work on
the craft
and there's certain writers that take to
this the art of writing like a duck to
water they will take direction really
quickly
they'll
you know they're not afraid of us doing
a first draft and then me saying
okay let's rip it apart because the
middle of the book should be where we
start the book and this c this chapter
should mix with this chapter and i think
we might need a different ending because
that's what happens when you do the
first draft the second draft is
really where the magic happens
there are some people that are not
afraid of that they're like let's they
roll up there let's let's do it and
there's other people that are like oh my
god what does that mean like we just i
just did this for like 12 weeks now
you're gonna we're gonna rip it apart
what is that and there's a lot more fear
of the process right which is
understandable because they just did a
process that they were not comfortable
with they just they're like oh phew i
just got through that and now we have oh
there's another process but inevitably
everybody at the end of the second draft
sees the light at the end of the tunnel
no matter where they were in the first
draft they're all like
this is
good some are more like a little bit
like we're on to something and other
other people are like oh my god this is
like
so excited like this is magic like magic
has happened
so i think by the end of the second
draft they all kind of feel like
professional writers some of them might
hang on a little bit to
uh
they might start to as it gets closer to
like going out and looking for a
publisher well do you think my writing
is good like are you sure it's up to
standard do you think my writing is good
enough
and
you know it's just assurance it's like
it's not that you're right it's not
whether your writing is right or wrong
it's are you communicating in a clear
entertaining and effective way something
that's going to inspire the reader and
drive them to take some kind of action
in their life right like
uh
maybe you're you're you're espousing
some kind of new philosophy have you
done a good enough job having them
actually sit up and go
i never thought about that i'm gonna
i'm gonna change the way i do that in my
life which is what a lot of great books
will do
why would someone be afraid to go
through the first draft whereas others
are like yeah let's do it rip it apart
like tell me the truth i think just that
that there's that there is a banality
even there's like a conflict right so
on one hand they've been told for years
by everybody under the sun you should
write a book
and so they believe and then there's
underneath a little part of them that
believes that right but they're coming
in a little bit driven on
external forces right so they'll come in
and they'll be like okay well i'm gonna
do it
kind of because everybody else said i
should do it and i kind of believe i
should do it
so i'm gonna write this thing
but there's in the back of their mind
still that like self-defeating mindset
that's like
and it's often can be a voice that says
who cares
does this really matter like you're
spending all this time and energy like
putting this out because what the valet
said you should write a story because
your aunt mary said you should write a
story
i don't know this seems like a lot of
time and a lot of you're spending a lot
of time with that kim lady how do you
even know she's qualified like
what even are her credentials and i joke
about this sometimes when i do talks
about what that voice will do to try to
keep you safe right because you've been
safe
you've gotten so far your ego's like
we're cool we're good and all of a
sudden you're like but i actually want
to tell them that he goes like no wait a
minute we've been good without you
telling all these stories why do you
want to upset the apple cart now so
that's more what i see coming into play
and it comes in all different ways it
comes in
tiers it comes in
argumentativeness it comes in
you know i see it all i have a lot of
very strong willed personality clients
and i see it come out in all different
ways
what about a third draft oh the third
draft is just heaven because we've
ripped it apart we've put it back
together we know exactly what the book
is and now we get to do like a lot of
bells and whistles so
um maybe we didn't find a system in the
book that we knew would have to be there
i used my client alan maxwell a lot for
this example he had written a a memoir
about his life from philadelphia to
becoming a top defense contractor in san
diego in the navy in between
and we were done with the third draft
and i said
we've done a beautiful book we've done a
beautiful job this is someone who knew
nothing about writing and dictated most
of his book and we had to like do a lot
of fixing on it but
got it done
in the airport on a busy schedule
and i said
this is a beautiful book we've done a
great job but who cares
and he looked at me and he went
what do you mean who cares and i said
how are we gonna make this something
that stands out amid all the other
people that thought that they should
write a memoir because he's not famous
and i said every time you write
something you talk about a system
that you've been in whether it's various
parts of the navy or
parts of society in georgia or
the government and i said
you've got some rules that you've
applied in your life to get through
those situations that you've then
carried into new situations
how many do you think you might have of
those rules he said i don't know let me
go let me go figure it out
so we came up with 15 rules
we then went back through the book on a
fourth draft
found all the places the rules would
apply and put them into the book and he
became a wall street journal top 10
business book wow
so we went from
great this is your life it's very
interesting but who are you and why
should we
be dialed in
to then you tapped into that a lot of
rules structures things interesting yeah
and we made it something that was for
anybody like
we had a 17 year old girl read it and
she was just blown away
yeah she was like i would take this as
my book that i would bring out into the
world and use because if you think about
it anytime we step into anywhere if you
have these tips that he gives and you
understand these rules apply and you're
savvy with them
you can figure out who your allies are
who your enemies are you know you can
figure out you can keep your eyes open
and attuned to certain certain
situations see the red flags you're
going to do pretty well
interesting so was it was it too vanilla
before or it was still interesting but
he wasn't giving the reader anything
exactly okay
and so is that something that
could be as we all think our lives are
fascinating and
okay they won't make a movie about me
but maybe if i write my book they'll
they'll right right but but is is that
what sometimes we're missing is what are
we offering the reader what are we
offering the reader and he actually has
some discreet
chapters that are standalone movies
without a doubt i mean he has
you know
uss destroyers getting song i mean he
has very exciting moments but that
wasn't enough right it's great to read
that that adds to his credibility
with his knowledge that he's sharing but
standalone it wasn't a hundred percent
enough
um
when people come to me write memoirs i
do say
what do you think of your like core
areas that you have
the
the golden thread or the line of
something your whole life you've kind of
not paid attention to so it might be
money messaging from childhood and then
money chaos money chaos money chaos
money chaos till finally they changed
something
and now they might not
still be great with money but they
they're free right and then all the
scenes support that through line someone
could read that and see their money
stories and see their pattern and so
it's like they they they are able to
have like some kind of epiphany or
recovery or learning curve
through being entertained in that
narrative
how do you know when a writer is holding
back so let's say i bring to you what i
think is a traumatic scene
and you read it and you say
yeah
it sounds traumatic but i'm not like
it's missing something's missing here
when they write more about okay so when
they write more about the other person
in the scene than them
that's how i know they're holding back
they're not talking about themselves
they're taking that other person's
inventory and it's more about that other
person so i'll say well this isn't a
book about that person how did you feel
in that situation that's a number one
example
you can actually see it before they even
start writing the book typically um
they'll a client will come to me
this isn't i don't mean typically in
this situation this is how it unfolds
i've got all this other writing that
i've done and i'd love for you to read
it all because i think i want to include
it all in the book and i'll go
well how much of their of it is there
and they'll say well i mean it's like a
couple short stories i wrote i think
there might be some nuggets in there and
i think oh we're never going to use any
of this but i think well i'll read it
right because i'm getting to know them
and it's it's it's almost like part of
the process because they're saying to me
this is who i was before i came to you
will you look at me right so they are
actually giving me an opportunity to see
where they're going to have to go from
and i'll read the material and i'll
either i'll glean from it they are this
kind of writer or this is what's been
important to them
we never use that material because i see
that they're going to like i see i get a
good idea i'm like okay this is i
understand where they're starting from i
understand why they're coming to me i
understand why they're showing me this
they're saying and a lot of times um the
material will have pretty graphics in it
and they've spent a lot of time
presenting it um
when they write books with me i'm like
do not put any graphics in the book
while we're writing it it's just
something we have to delete move around
it's just it's technical stuff words
just words don't
dressing it up is not gonna change my
edit notes like i'm gonna come i'm not
you're not gonna like fool me with the
pictures right
um and so that's one way that i see that
they might be
like a little more resistant to being
honest
i had a client once who wrote an entire
book with me for
two drafts
and it was at the end of the second
draft
i don't i don't know if i missed it
or she just threw it in kind of like
slid it in
but it
i read it and i realized that
something had happened to her as a baby
in a crib
it was abuse
and
she hadn't even realized
and she didn't even realize she'd
written it
and
that was
that was painful
that was that was it was it was
it was hard to call it out and it was
hard for her to process it
so
i think if you want to tell it'll come
out
right
whether you know it or not whether you
know it or not the words kind of
they don't lie that'll be the truth
it's like freudian slips
very true
how common is it for a writer to not
believe in themselves
i mean does anybody ever really believe
in themselves who's a that are that is a
writer i mean i have days i think i
think it varies from day to day i i
think that um one thing i've been doing
lately is i'm part of a writing group
and we will write and read out loud and
nobody will
say anything
you just read and it's thank you
um
and then another part of that group
which is more of an advanced group
we will read a chapter and then the
group will comment on it
and i think that that takes away when
you're able to present and perform
you get out of that headspace that i'm
all alone and on any given day it's all
about me i'm either good or i'm bad
good or bad it's hardly ever
well that was a good day it's it's never
in the middle yes i think as a writer
you're either [ __ ] or you're amazing so
when you are in a group and you're
reading to other people
you realize that there's a lot of good
things about your writing there's some
things that need to be fixed about your
writing oh i didn't expect that person
would like that oh i really like how i
sounded oh wow i'm writing about all
these gosh i keep using that voice wow
i'm really snarky there's so many other
things to think about versus good or bad
and that's where i try to get writers to
work from like what are your strengths
what are some of the areas you could
improve
um if that's not something you're very
interested in getting better then maybe
we'll have someone come in and do maybe
like some edits on that for you or you
know uh
but rarely does anyone say oh i'm not
i'm not a good writer i think they're
pretty pretty proud of themselves by the
time they get through three drafts if
anything they're very proud of the work
they just did week after week
there was the the vigilance
and the resiliency
no matter what to sit down at that
computer
and write a chapter even if it's
something they want to just throw
against the wall in absolute disgust you
know
i've had them turn in chapters and and
say um
well i'm turning it in
dot dot dot you're like
you know the rest of that sentence is
but i think it's terrible
and it never is
what about the flip side those that
think it's amazing and actually
maybe they're not seeing
themselves and i mean it's they're
blinded by something that's a great
question i do
um no experience i have had experiences
like that where
they're on a journey and you could all
you can just be their guide
so
you can tell that a lot of what they're
writing probably belongs in a journal
and might need some more extensive
therapy before it goes out in the world
it's definitely a little bit of a dump
maybe a little bit of a [ __ ] show
um
but that's not my
i'm not a
i'm not to judge their experience so if
they're done with it and they say and i
might say
this felt a little
hard are you sure you want to come out
and say that about like your mom or
that ex-husband or like you know i know
we're going to change some names but
that just was that's
whoa
that's real you're going for the jugular
on that one
i know
that's who they're going to be
and i don't i am i am
you know
hats off to you like i've given the
disclaimer
um
because what will happen is is that
they'll go out and try to sell the book
and a lot of times with a little bit of
my guidance depending on
whether they're still coaching with me
or not but they'll go out and i've
become friends with most of these people
at this point so
um i am
i have a lot invested emotionally with
them but
they'll find out sooner or later because
someone will say this feels like
an emotional dump and then they'll have
to go
you know maybe i should like get rid of
that one scene with the you know and
some people need more of a rewrite and
they don't have time or money anymore to
do a rewrite so they might have to sit
on it for a while
so if it feels really heavy if i'm like
whoa this is not i'm not moved but this
is almost like uncomfortable for me then
maybe it is this dump is is that how
yeah it's not really for the reader it's
for the writer still and you want to get
it to a place where it's for the reader
to then have their experience and feel
like
i just heard someone say that like
angela's ashes he wrote that for 10
years or something because he
wanted to write it until he wasn't angry
anymore
so that the experience could be for the
reader
what is your process for coaching belief
into someone well i always just say the
fact that they signed up for a one-year
program and they're showing up every
week is
already
pretty amazing and really impressive
um i'm always giving like positive notes
like love or
that was amazing or look how you turned
that around or this is incredible
in my one year program there isn't a lot
of time to not believe in yourself it's
so rigorous and it's so continual
that i don't really think it's belief
that trips them up because once they
start getting going they just want to do
the work and finish it because they're
committed
um i think belief falls more into
uh people that aren't
there yet right so that would be more in
the own your authorship class that's
people who
you know it's a lot more like
cheerleading and a lot more showing them
the light of the vision that they have
that they can get to the finish line
that they are worthy of writing uh that
they just they deserve you know they
they can have that desire as much as
anybody else can have that desire so
there's a lot more coaching belief in
i would say the uh
in those early early foundational and
fundamental classes
but my one-year clients
they're pretty badass
they they
signing up for a one-year program and
and and putting out twenty thousand
dollars you already better believe
because you're invested
does anyone get scared because they know
people will read it
and they may identify they may even
though names are changed and think but
they're just afraid even you know yeah
it's traumatic to divulge secrets i've
had clients sit on their books for a
little bit longer than i thought they
should have but that was their process
that they needed to go through and then
when they did actually release the book
they were ready
um and so they're ready you know when
they're ready
um or they had to like
the book had shown them something about
themselves and so they had to go be with
that new self for a little while and
then
maybe start a podcast or open another
version of their business and they knew
the book was good so it's not like it
was getting stale
they knew that they could bring it out
when they felt like they were in a in a
successful space
and so sometimes that might be six
months after they're done
after a year i start to
to hassle them what happened to your
book what happened to your book what
happened to your book and some people
it doesn't happen much anymore but in my
early days of coaching there were people
that wrote the book just to write the
book
they were done they were like i'm good
something i wanted to do in retirement i
don't really think i have time and
energy to go through the whole
publishing process i'm really happy i
did it i feel like i wanted it down on
paper for legacy
and
i just don't think i need to publish it
sometimes i've seen comments that when
someone's written about let's say a
famous parent
that whatever the public's perception of
that individual is
they end up getting mad at the at the
writer
because maybe
they're divulging things that we don't
want to see that side of that person
right have you ever talked about
you know the the criticism that could
come for divulging secrets or speaking
about whatever oh yeah isn't seen as
honoring
whomever
i like to say if you're getting that
kind of criticism you're doing well with
your book
because nobody criticizes a book nobody
cares about
so
i believe to get that level of criticism
you have to have a lot of eyeballs on
your book
a lot of eyeballs on your book to kind
of kick up that kind of
you know dissent about it right that
many people have to be reading it so i i
look at that as kind of a win it's like
good they're fired up
tell more people to read it because
they're going to be fired up and they're
going to be upset and
i haven't had anybody write about
anybody famous
um
i do have a client who wrote about a lot
of there were hollywood people in it
she hasn't published yet um
but she wasn't
she was like that's the way it went down
and i was there so
it's not like contestable really because
it's exactly what happened and there
were witnesses so
um
you know we don't like in general our
bubbles burst if that if that's the
bubble it's going to be burst for you
and you chose that book to read it maybe
you were looking to get that bubble
burst anyway you just don't know it on a
subconscious level
what are five steps to writing a bad
book only talking about yourself without
a a
purpose
or a mission
of something that you want to have the
reader experience like
joy or
a journey or
an emotional release i'm talking more in
memoir and self-help
um
using
language like it and this
and maybe
and perhaps in like kind of vague terms
instead of rewriting the sentences every
sentence should be a thing of beauty
um
it's a book take your time to make every
line matter don't just think well those
sentences were good these can be kind of
a slough off
rewrite every make every sentence
beautiful
um
don't
aim low
don't decide i'm just going to write an
ebook and give it away for free on your
website
i don't think that's not really a book
honor books
they're boundable
they're thicker
it's something you want to hand to
someone and be proud of not some door
stop or something i'm going to use to
balance
my computer
um
that's four
and
five would be
write one draft and then publish it
why would someone do that people do it
all the time they're like that was
brilliant nailed it in one shot
and they just discount the whole process
that that was just the beginning
you read it you can tell you can tell
when someone's published for you you
don't see that in profession
professional but you see that in
you know when i was in like networking
groups or like you know first started my
business people would write books in 90
days or whatever and
you're like i don't want to read it
please don't give me your book this is
what i would be thinking because it
would just be
fluffy
it would spin it where they were
it was too positive or no it just
wouldn't have you can't i mean
to really dig in and write a memoir in a
short period of time i don't think it's
got enough heft it hasn't been expanded
enough
maybe to write a book about dating like
101 tips to date you might be able to do
that in the first draft
or
10 tips to good sales calls you might be
able to do that in one draft
but i don't tend to work with those
books
when you read
an author's work and they write about
themselves in too positive a light
how do you break that down because we've
all read books where oh yeah it was
written by this ceo or this person and
they're just telling their grand vision
and it paints them as the saint
whereas when you read about a third
party writing about that same individual
it's much juicier
it's a full person
warts and all so how do you when you see
somebody's being too
pollyanna about themselves
how do you say
are we really getting honest here i
don't ever get that
i don't ever get that i think that
there's a lot of self-deprecation
in
the clients that come to me i think that
they've been through enough of the rough
road that self-deprecation is not
it's not so far from them and um if
anything we're trying to get them to be
more positive about themselves and and
see where their beautiful gifts are and
see how what they've written about and
what they've been through
inform so much about who they are
i don't i can't think of one experience
where someone just wants to write
about
their positive experiences i mean i have
had those conversations where people
have called me and they're like well i'm
gonna write a book about and i and i
feel like kind of a cynic going but
where's the darkness right especially
when they say
well there really isn't anything dark
about my story and i think oh i don't
know if that's possible who wants to
read it where did you live
[Laughter]
yeah would you say a lot of new writers
write books that are mediocre or have no
essence no not at all i mean i think
it's i think
everybody's a new writer on any project
you start i'm a new writer even though
i've been writing since i was 12 years
old
anytime you take on a new narrative
or a new group of characters or maybe a
new style of writing
or
you're going into new territory
you're new you know you might have more
of a bag of tools with you you might
know
better paragraph structure
you might do better bridges in and out
of your chapters
you might
know not to bring in too many characters
in the whole kitchen sink you might have
your themes broken down your why broken
down and your bigger message and you
know who you're writing for and you know
what you're an expert in but you're
still new
it's still a fresh slate you're still
gonna have all the same butterflies in
your stomach you're still gonna have all
the same
you know disembarking on this like
amazing journey and i always say books
are a journey not a destination you're
really not ever really getting anywhere
even like
you're you're in a journey like if you
get there the journey's over what books
should continue forever
explain to me what a bridge is between
chapel a bridge is leading out of one
chapter into the next chapter so it it
either summarizes and concludes the the
first the chapter that's just ending and
leads you into the next chapter with a
flow so you don't feel just
that one chapter ends and then the next
chapter starts there's some kind of with
fiction it's a little bit different
especially if you're jumping around
locations but there is some kind of
uh there's a there's a skill involved in
leading the reader in through
like a tapestry of the chapters and
that's what the bridges do and that's
really what we do in the third draft as
we work on the bridges
how can you tell a story is boring or
it's wandering
what tips do you have to
like you said with the one gentleman who
had an interesting career
but
it needed it needed um these 15 tips
i like people to write their story first
first draft before i start killing their
babies is what i the way i call it and
that's um
i get pretty brutal
like i'll start to go through and just
be like why do we care
and who's this for and what does this do
and why do we need this and
if i get some pushback i'll listen
because there could be something that
isn't really be being said
and we'll have sometimes like a debate
about it like
well what do you mean that the the the
that you say that this is about that
character's evolution i don't see any
evolution here at all i see or just
washing dishes in the kitchen with their
grandmother where's the evolution well
the grandmother threw the thing and well
you didn't write that the grandmother
threw the thing you just wrote oh
then they go and write it
and it's
now a scene that almost is like required
so you don't try to you don't try to
throw it you might have entire
storylines that just go right because
sometimes it seems all seems relevant on
the first draft and then in the second
draft
we don't need everybody to know every
single
part of your life we just need the parts
that serve the themes that are running
through and if that chunk does not serve
the theme
they're not going to know the difference
whether you kept it out or not because
they don't know you
they only know what you're going to tell
them you want them to know
so if we're like oh grandpa john he
would make these great birdhouses and
he's just no do we is grandpa john
necessary right to the story oh he was a
really cool guy he was i would we would
watch these no no is he necessary right
no grandpa john's gone sorry yeah
and how do people feel about that when
it's like
that was grandpa john he's got to be in
the story he was a big part of the
family but there wasn't enough
and i'm like you can put grandpa john in
the book for grandpa john but that's not
going to help your book
we need to focus on the book what does
the book need what is you know maybe you
can write a little letter to grandpa
john or something put them in the put
them in the acknowledgements
okay right with a picture no well that's
right we're not doing pictures
no pictures no graphics